Você sabia que existe um inimigo
silencioso dormindo dentro de 95% das
pessoas que estão assistindo a esse
vídeo agora? E o pior, ele pode acordar
a qualquer momento. Um estudo bombástico
da Universidade de Stanford, publicado
agora em novembro de 2025 na Science
Translational Medicine, analisou mais de
300.000 1 células e descobriu algo
assustador. O vírus bar não apenas causa
a chamada doença do beijo na
adolescência e vai embora, ele fica no
seu organismo. Ele tem a capacidade de
hackear o seu sistema imune, reprogramar
sua células de defesa e dar a ordem para
elas atacarem seus próprios órgãos,
sendo o gatilho principal pro lupus e
possivelmente esclerose múltipla e
artriteide. Se você sofre com fadiga que
não passa, dores no corpo, que os
médicos dizem ser fibromialgia ou
estresse, ou se já tem uma autoimune e
não sabe a causa, preste muita atenção.
Hoje eu vou te mostrar como identificar
se esse vírus está ativo em você e o que
a visão funcional propõe para colocar
ele de volta para dormir.
Olá, pessoal. Dr. Alan Dutra aqui. Vamos
conversar sério. Sabe aquela sensação de
que você está batalhando contra o
próprio corpo? Pois é, talvez você
esteja mesmo. Mas o culpado não é o
azar, é biologia. A maioria de nós pegou
osten sigla eV na infância ou
adolescência. Teve febre, tor de
garganta, gangulos inchados ou às vezes
nem sentiu nada. A medicina ortodoxa
diz: "Ah, você já teve, criou
anticorpos, fim de papo." Mas a visão
funcional sempre se confiou que não era
bem assim. E agora a ciência de ponta
confirmou que a gente respeitava. O
estúdio Stanford é um divisor de águas.
Os pesquisadores descobriram que o vírus
se esconde nas células B, que são
justamente as células de elite do nosso
sistema de defesa responsáveis por
produzir anticorpos. O EBV entra lá e
faz uma verdadeira gambiarra genética.
Ele liga genes que deveriam estar
desligados. E o resultado, essas células
B que deveriam nos proteger são
reprogramadas para se tornarem
autoreativas, ou seja, elas começam a
atacar o próprio corpo. O estudo mostrou
que estas células infectadas e
reprogramadas são 25 vezes mais comuns
em pacientes com lupos do que em pessoas
saudáveis. É como se o vírus vestisse o
uniforme da polícia, entrasse na
delegacia e começasse a dar ordens
falsas para prender cidadãos inocentes.
Mas, Dr. Alan, eu não tenho lupus. Por
que que eu devo me preocupar com isso?
Porque o lupus é o extremo do espectro.
Antes de chegar lá, existe uma zona
cinzenta. Quando o vírus reativa e ele
reativa por estresse, falta de sono,
toxinas ou pósinfecções virais, ele gera
uma inflamação sistêmica de baixo grau.
Sabe aquela neblina mental, névoa
mental, aquela dor articular migratória,
aquela tireoide que oscila, rachimoto
tem uma forte ligação comstembar, EBV,
pode ser uma reativação viral
subclínica. O vírus está lá cutucando o
seu sistema imune, gastando sua energia
e roubando suas mitocôndrias. O grande
erro que eu vejo no consultório e
acontece com oito a cada 10 pacientes
que chegam até mim é o diagnóstico
incompleto. O médico pede o exame de
sangue, vê o IGG positivo e diz: "Isso é
cicatriz imunológica, coisa antiga e
para por aí". Isso muitas vezes pode
estar errado. Para saber se o vírus está
acordado e causando estrago agora, você
precisa pedir um marcador específico
chamado abstenin early antigen. É o tal
do EA, o antígeno precoce. Se o early
antigen tiver positivo, não importa se a
infecção foi há 20 anos. O vírus está se
replicando agora. Além disso, olhamos o
VCA e GM, que é infecção aguda, e o
EBNA, que é infecção passada. Mas o pulo
do gato é o early antigen. Anote isso no
seu caderninho aí. Agora, o que fazer?
Na visão funcional, não existe remédio
mágico para matar o vírus 100%, mas
existe protocolo para algemar ele e
colocar de volta na prisão. O protocolo
básico que eu uso na clínica para
modular essa resposta envolve três
pilares. Primeiro, cortar o combustível
do vírus. O epistem bar adora açúcar e
estresse. Se você vive com a insulina
alta e o cortisol no teto, você está
servindo um banquete pro vírus. Segundo,
suplementação estratégica. Na fase de
ataque, usamos muito a lisina,
aminoácido top. O vírus precisa de um
amino chamado arginina para se replicar
e a lisina compete com a arginina e
freia a reprodução viral. Usamos doses
de ataque longe das refeições junto com
a monolaurina que é extraída do óleo de
coco e ajuda a dissolver o envelope
lipítico de vírus envelopados como o EBV
e claro vitamina C zinco para dar aquela
munição aos soldados que sobraram. O
terceiro pilar é o gerenciamento do
stresse. Parece clichê, mas não é. O
estudo mostrou que o vírus aproveita
brechas, o cortisol alto suprime a
vigilância do sistema imune e é nessa
hora que o MBV sai da latência. Por
isso, rir, dormir cedo, meditar não é
good vibes, é tratamento antiviral
potente. Se você tem autoimune na
família ou sintomas inexplicáveis,
investigue o EBV. Não aceite o e normal
da idade. E para fechar, uma verdade
incômoda. O YouTube e o próprio ambiente
regulatório me obrigam a simplificar
muita coisa aqui. Eu preciso cortar
detalhes de dose, suavizar protocolos
mais avançados e evitar combinações of
label que na prática clínica fazem
diferença real. Então dentro da
comunidade fechada, eu não preciso
colocar esse filtro. Lá eu compartilho
exatamente os protocolos que eu uso em
consultório, casos de reversão que
pareciam impossíveis se eu contasse
insoltos, combinações avançadas e
fornecedores confiáveis, além de
interpretação fina de exames e
atualizações de artigos linha por linha.
É praticamente ter acesso direto ao meu
raciocínio clínico. Temos dois níveis
nesse nosso grupo. Temos lives semanais,
materiais em PDF com dezenas de
protocolos e grupo exclusivo no
WhatsApp. Você deixa de ser um
espectador passivo e passa a fazer parte
do ciclo interno que está realmente
comprometido em dominar a medicina
funcional aplicada com profundidade, sem
superficialidade de rede social. Se isso
faz sentido para você, o botão seja
membro está aqui embaixo. Poucos têm
coragem de dar esse passo. A pergunta é:
você está entre esses poucos?
Agradecimentos especiais a nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube. Nível
dois, Dr. Ana Paulo Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Burtinho, Fernando Machado,
Sou Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mares, Eloterapias
Integrativas, Luís Anselmo Neves, Antes
da Doença. Eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado.